hey guys nostalgia critic here sorry I
can't do my usual editorial this week
but I guess I've been some of this in a
franchise or something I don't know I'll
keep you updated anyway here's all
something I put together just in case
some sort of distraction came up
how did you know she was a Nazi she
talked foolishly
who did this
Uncle Frank and aunt Jack put her there
it's your mom dude
there's somebody here to see you
just the pussy I've been looking for
single white female wanted for
mysterious expedition what do you think
smoothies having women and semen don't
mix nice booby trap I just love
skinny-dipping hey
turn around you horny toad fun Bob
doesn't have hair
Suzie thanks big man we've all been
touched by your fitness coupling firm
muscles I might be oh baby oh baby
sorry we pull up won't have room for
another 20 minutes
oh we have to each other Marcin you can
help roll out how long you want just
kill them all
all night okay let me be the first to
welcome you aboard
Choki chicken incorporated knock off the
crying that's not my grave what did you
just jump on our doggystyle bow ride
everybody on their hands and knees